Here's an editorial from a newspaper in Jackson, Mississippi, The Clarion-Ledger, from October 6, 1957. "If you want an insight into how Negroes in Chicago are trying to establish social equality," it begins, "there are three paragraphs from an authentic report of a meeting of the Negro Improvement Society in that city." And then it quotes from the report.
这是一篇摘自1957年10月6日密西西比州杰克逊市《号角纪事报》的社论。文章开头写道：“如果你想了解芝加哥的黑人是如何试图建立社会平等的，那么这里有该市黑人进步协会一次会议的真实报道中的三段文字。”随后它引用了该报道的内容。
"To those who failed to attend our recent quarterly meeting, I can say you missed a real treat. At the last minute, we were able to get Mayor Daley as speaker. He presented a very interesting talk. The highlight of it was a discussion of the forthcoming campaign 'Take a Negro Boy Home Tonight,' which all agreed was a fine step forward in human relations. It is to be inaugurated soon in the city's high schools.
“对于那些没能参加我们最近季度会议的人，我想说你们错过了一次真正的盛会。最后一刻，我们请到了戴利市长作为演讲嘉宾。他发表了一场非常有趣的谈话。其中最精彩的部分是关于即将开展的‘今晚带个黑人男孩回家’运动的讨论，大家都一致认为这是人际关系向前迈出的重要一步。该运动即将在全市的高中启动。”
Mayor Daley told us that he had been advised by an outstanding sociologist that the vicious hates and fears rooted in racial prejudice and fascist bigotry could best be combated by closer and more intimate relationships between Negro boys and white girls. Therefore this new campaign will encourage white high school girls to volunteer to take Negro boys to their homes for dinner and date them afterwards. These girls will get higher marks and other privileges for promoting interracial harmony. This will show the white parents that it's all right to have these associations.
戴利市长告诉我们，一位杰出的社会学家曾建议他，植根于种族偏见和法西斯偏执之中的恶毒仇恨与恐惧，最好通过黑人男孩与白人女孩之间更亲密的关系来消除。因此，这项新运动将鼓励白人女高中生主动报名，在晚餐时把黑人男孩带回家，并在此后与他们约会。这些促进种族和谐的女孩将获得更高的分数和其他特权。这将向白人父母表明，这些交往是没问题的。
Now we must all do our part. Make sure that Negro boys invited to the white folks' houses take a bath first and put on a white shirt. Then he will prove that he's a good companion for the white girls and socially acceptable. Please cooperate to make Mayor Daley's campaign a success."
现在我们必须各尽其责。确保受邀到白人家庭做客的黑人男孩先洗澡并穿上白衬衫。这样他就能证明自己是白人女孩的好伴侣，并且在社会上是可以接受的。请配合行动，让戴利市长的运动取得成功。”
And then after that, the editorial continues. "So that's the way they're trying to establish racial equality in Chicago, equality with miscegenation, mixed marriages, wholesale adultery, bastardy, and mongrelization. It is happening in Chicago. It will be tried in Mississippi if the NAACP ever gets a foot in the door."
社论在此之后继续写道：“这就是他们在芝加哥试图建立种族平等的方式，一种伴随着种族通婚、混血婚姻、大规模通奸、私生子和杂种化的平等。这种事正在芝加哥发生。如果全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）在密西西比州有了立足之地，这也会在这里上演。”
Well, you know, the most interesting thing about this campaign, "Take a Negro Boy Home  Tonight," is that it is complete fiction. No such campaign ever existed in Chicago. And if it did, you know, it's unimaginable to any real Chicagoan that the late Mayor Richard J. Daley would have endorsed it. These kinds of articles appeared in Southern newspapers at least as far back as the 1920s. Lies made up by segregationist forces to scare white people about this threat, racial integration.
你知道，关于“今晚带个黑人男孩回家”这场运动最有趣的一点是，它完全是虚构的。芝加哥从未存在过这样的运动。即使有，对于任何真正的芝加哥人来说，已故市长理查德·J·戴利会支持这种事也是不可想象的。这类文章早在20世纪20年代就开始出现在南方报纸上了。这些谎言是由种族隔离主义势力编造的，目的是恐吓白人，让他们对种族融合这一威胁感到恐惧。
And the lies worked for a while. And then integration came anyway. Which brings us to today's radio program. Today we bring you two stories of people who tried, in one way or another, to bring a Negro boy home for the night. Act One is a story about intermarriage. Act Two is a story about trying to take a kid out of the ghetto and put him into the Ivy League, and why that's so difficult. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这些谎言确实奏效了一段时间。但融合最终还是到来了。这把我们带到了今天的广播节目。今天我们要讲两个故事，关于那些以某种方式试图带个黑人男孩回家过夜的人。第一幕是关于跨种族婚姻的故事。第二幕是关于试图将一个孩子从贫民窟带出来并送进常春藤盟校的故事，以及为什么这如此困难。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
"October 30, 1966. Hello, home. Well, I went to have the tire patched--"
“1966年10月30日。你好，家里。嗯，我去补了轮胎——”
This is a typical letter home from college. There's chitchat about a tire that needed to be fixed and senior class pictures, how much they should cost, and should she pay for better ones so her grandmother could have a better one? And then slowly, the woman writing this letter gets to the whole point of the letter.
这是一封典型的大学寄回家的信。里面有关于需要修理的轮胎和毕业照的闲聊，比如照片应该花多少钱，她是否应该多花点钱买更好的，这样她祖母就能拿到一张更好的照片？然后，写信的女人慢慢地转入正题。
"I went to a good play last night, Misalliance by George Bernard Shaw. A friend of mine was in it, but he wasn't any good. I went with Richard Robinson." Oh! "A track runner, singer, dancer, all-around good looker, religious, and liked by everyone. He's one of the nicest people I know. And he's Negro.
“昨晚我去看了一场精彩的戏剧，乔治·萧伯纳的《错配》。我的一个朋友在里面演出，但他演得不好。我是和理查德·罗宾逊一起去的。” 哦！“一个田径运动员、歌手、舞者，各方面都很出色，有宗教信仰，大家都喜欢他。他是我认识的最善良的人之一。而且他是黑人。”
I had to tell you. I've never kept any secrets from you and this wasn't going to be one. I hope you're not angry. Even you would like him. No one minded. Bill Crowell was there and real nice to both of us. I don't know why there has to be a racial problem anyway. I had so much better time with him than I do with Bob or David [? Kiechle ?] or Bill Crowell or Roger Heckerman and he treated me like a queen. Sad, isn't it? Please don't think I'm being a rebel. I love you both very much and am proud to be close enough to my parents to tell them everything, whether or not I know they will disagree with me. I'm sure it makes us all better people. I love you, OK? Love, Julia.
我必须告诉你。我从没对你隐瞒过任何秘密，这也不会是例外。希望你没有生气。连你都会喜欢他的。没人介意。比尔·克罗威尔也在场，对我们两个都很好。我不知道为什么非得有种族问题。我和他在一起比和鲍勃、大卫·基赫勒、比尔·克罗威尔或罗杰·赫克曼在一起要开心得多，他待我如皇后。很可悲，不是吗？请不要认为我是个叛逆者。我非常爱你们俩，也很自豪能和父母亲近到可以告诉他们一切，无论我知道他们是否会不同意。我相信这会让我们都变得更好。我爱你们，好吗？爱你们的，朱莉娅。
Well, the narrator of our first story is not actually this woman. It's her son named Rich Robinson, one of the three children she had with the Negro boy after she brought him home for the night and married him. She and her husband got together in that period in the '60s after the passage of the Voting Rights Act and before the assassination of Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr. And they lived the dream of interracial marriage for 12 years. And then, around the time that our nation started edging away from the goals and ideals of the Civil Rights Movement, they split up.
我们第一个故事的讲述者其实不是这个女人。而是她的儿子，名叫里奇·罗宾逊，她在那次带黑人男孩回家过夜并嫁给他之后所生的三个孩子之一。她和她的丈夫是在60年代《投票权法》通过之后，马丁·路德·金博士遇刺之前的那段时期走到一起的。他们实现了跨种族婚姻的梦想，持续了12年。然后，就在我们国家开始背离民权运动的目标和理想的时候，他们分开了。
The woman, Julia, has remarried to a white guy named Jan. The man, Richard Sr., remarried to a black woman named Debbie. And each of them returned to their separate, segregated worlds, leaving the kids to figure out what to make of the whole experiment. To what degree did race push them apart, destroy their marriage? And for that matter, to what degree had race brought them together in the first place?
女人朱莉娅再嫁给了一个叫简的白人。男人理查德一世再娶了一个叫黛比的黑人女性。他们各自回到了自己被种族隔离的世界，留下孩子们去琢磨整个实验到底意味着什么。种族在多大程度上将他们推开并摧毁了他们的婚姻？再说，种族起初又在多大程度上将他们拉到了一起？
Well, a few months ago, their son, Rich Robinson, went to figure all this out. And they were subjects that he had never discussed, incredibly had never discussed, with either of his parents. Here's his story.
几个月前，他们的儿子里奇·罗宾逊去弄清楚这一切。这些是他从未与父母任何一方讨论过，令人难以置信地从未讨论过的课题。这是他的故事。
When I started working on this story, I didn't realize there was a question about my life-- my life today-- at the heart of it. Then one Sunday morning, I got into this discussion with my roommates. And the topic switched from my parents to mixed marriages in the '60s to me. I was saying that I date both white and black women. They were saying I was crazy.
当我开始做这个故事时，我并没有意识到它核心里还隐藏着关于我生活的问题——我今天的生活。后来一个周日早上，我和室友讨论起来。话题从我父母转到60年代的混合婚姻，又转到我身上。我说我在和白人女性和黑人女性约会。他们说我疯了。
OK, Sam?
好了，萨姆？
She was half.
她是混血。
She was half Venezuelan. That's not--
她是委内瑞拉混血。那不是——
She was white. She was white all through--
她是白人。她彻头彻尾都是白人——
She was white.
她是白人。
--and through, my friend.
——彻头彻尾，我的朋友。
They start listing all the women that they know I've dated, about seven of them. Sam was half Colombian, Julianna, who's Brazilian, Amanda--
他们开始列举他们知道我约会过的所有女性，大约七个。萨姆是哥伦比亚混血，朱莉安娜是巴西人，阿曼达——
Amanda. Can you get any whiter? She's more white than the white people that I know. I don't know. Who else? Pam? Amy? Can't get any whiter than that. Julianna. OK, I'll give you a 10% darkness over there. Why are you so worried about this thing? Are you worried that you're going to end up marrying a white girl?
阿曼达。你还能找到比她更白的吗？她比我认识的那些白人还要白。我不知道。还有谁？帕姆？艾米？没法比那更白了。朱莉安娜。好吧，我给你加10%的深色成分。你为什么这么担心这件事？你是担心你最终会娶一个白人女孩吗？
First of all, I'm never going to marry a white girl.
首先，我永远不会娶一个白人女孩。
Why?
为什么？
Why is that?
这是为什么？
It's just a bad idea.
这只是个坏主意。
Why?
为什么？
Because they'll never understand.
因为她们永远不会理解。
I hadn't put a lot of thought behind my answer to their question. I just knew in my mind that I had an answer, though I had never said this out loud to anyone. I always just assumed I would never marry a white girl, that those relationships don't work out, probably because I watched my parents' interracial marriage end. I assumed that race had something to do with it, that my blond-haired, blue-eyed, Indiana farm girl mother and my black, Brooklyn-born father were doomed from the start, destined to end up in separate worlds.
对于他们的这个问题，我并没有深思熟虑。我只是在心里知道我有一个答案，尽管我从没对任何人说出口。我总是理所当然地认为我永远不会娶一个白人女孩，认为这种关系不会有好结果，大概是因为我目睹了我父母跨种族婚姻的终结。我以为种族与之有关，我那金发碧眼、来自印第安纳农场的白人母亲和那个在布鲁克林出生的黑人父亲从一开始就注定失败，命中注定要走向各自的世界。
Now that they're divorced, my parents' integration is completely undone, except for my sisters and me. Though, if you ask my white grandmother, my mother's mother, my sisters and I aren't proof of anything.
现在他们离婚了，我父母的融合完全被抹去了，除了我和我的姐妹们。虽然如果你去问我那个白人祖母，我母亲的母亲，我姐妹和我并不能证明什么。
I said you don't sound like a black person than you aren't black, because I'm white and you're my grandson.
我说你听起来不像个黑人，那你就不黑，因为我是白人，而你是我的孙子。
So black people should sound a certain way?
所以黑人就该有个特定的样子？
They do. I don't know why they should or not.
确实如此。我不知道为什么非得如此，或者不该如此。
Do all white people sound alike?
所有的白人听起来都一样吗？
Well, they don't-- there's a few them that may sound a little black or a little like they're from the South, I should say. But I don't know. No no, no. Of course they don't all sound black. But you sure don't.
嗯，他们不是——有少数人可能听起来有点像黑人，或者我该说，听起来有点像南方人。但我不知道。不，不，不。他们当然不会都听起来像黑人。但你确实不像。
Well, what does black sound like?
那么，黑人听起来是什么样的？
Well, I want to know why you didn't have many black friends in high school. I never saw you with a black person in high school. Are you about to tell me that you had some black friends in high school?
嗯，我想知道为什么你在高中时没几个黑人朋友。我在高中从没见过你和黑人在一起。你该不会要告诉我你在高中时有一些黑人朋友吧？
Would that make me black?
如果我有，会让我变成黑人吗？
Well, I just wonder. I'm just getting back at you. You're almost like you're accusing me.
我只是好奇。我只是在反驳你。你简直像是在指责我。
So how do you see your grandkids racially, then?
那么你从种族角度来看待你的孙子们呢？
White. I really do.
白人。我真的是这么看。
Why is that?
那是为什么？
Because I'm white. I don't-- I can't help it. I just can't see you being black. I just can't. Really.
因为我是白人。我没——我没办法。我就是无法想象你是黑人。我就是无法想象。真的。
Is it embarrassing to think you have black grandchildren?
想到你有黑人孙辈会感到尴尬吗？
Not to me, it isn't. I don't think I got any black grandchildren. Not at all.
对我来说不是。我不觉得我有任何黑人孙辈。一点也不。
So my grandmother has an issue with me being black, my parents have issues with each other, and I have issues with white girls. But that's today, when everything is already messed up. Let's go back to a simpler time, before it all began.
所以我的祖母对我是黑人有意见，我的父母对彼此有意见，而我对白人女孩有意见。但这只是现在，当一切都搞砸了的时候。让我们回到一个更简单的时代，在这一切开始之前。
Both my parents went to Indiana University in the '60s. That's where they met. Mom had been valedictorian. She was in college on scholarship. She was going to be a foreign language major, and when she graduated, she was going to be a translator for the UN. Part of the plan was to go to Europe for a semester. When she came back, her roommate had been assigned to someone else, and she had gotten a new roommate, a black girl named Clara.
我父母都是60年代印第安纳大学的学生。他们就是在那儿认识的。我妈曾是毕业典礼上的优秀代表。她靠奖学金上大学。她打算主修外语，毕业后去联合国当翻译。计划的一部分是去欧洲待一个学期。当她回来时，她的室友被分配给了别人，她得到了一位新室友，一个叫克拉拉的黑人女孩。
And that was my first experience of really mixing with the black kids, because Clara and I would go to lunch together, or meals together. And I would sit at a table with black kids. And so that was really kind of how it happened.
那是我第一次真正与黑人孩子打交道，因为克拉拉和我经常一起去吃午饭，或者一起吃饭。我会和黑人孩子坐在一张桌子上。所以事情就是这样发生的。
And then I started going to functions with Clara. Clara would go to the black fraternity and sorority parties and I would go. I don't know if I would have done that before I went to Europe. I think going to Europe had something to do with it just because it broadened my way of thinking, perhaps. If I hadn't gone to Europe and been assigned a black roommate, I don't think it would have happened.
然后我开始和克拉拉一起参加活动。克拉拉会去黑人的联谊会和女生联谊会派对，我也会去。我不知道去欧洲之前我是否会这么做。我认为去欧洲和这有关系，只是因为它拓宽了我的思维方式，或许吧。如果我没去欧洲，没被分配到一个黑人室友，我想这一切都不会发生。
Well, I used to go watch him practice track a lot, which was over here. You want to go over there? Because that was--
嗯，我以前经常去看他练习田径，就在这边。你想去那边看看吗？因为那是——
My mom and I drove around the Indiana University campus. She showed me where she and my dad met, where they lived, and where they went to parties and dances at my dad's black fraternity, Omega Psi Phi.
我妈带我开车绕着印第安纳大学校园转。她向我展示了她和我爸见面的地方，他们住的地方，以及他们去参加我爸的黑人联谊会——欧米茄·派·菲联谊会——派对和舞会的地方。
You know the other thing that was just kind of hard for me to get used to was that their parties never started until 10:00 at night. At least 10:00, maybe later. And we had dorm curfews then. And I was still a pretty good girl. I didn't stay out all night. So I had to stay out all night with him because I couldn't get back into the dorm. And that was an annoyance to me. I always thought, why can't they start the parties like normal white people do?
你知道另一件让我有点难以习惯的事是，他们的派对从来不在晚上10点之前开始。至少是10点，也许更晚。我们当时有宿舍宵禁。我当时还是个挺乖的女孩。我不会在外面待一整晚。所以我不得不跟他一起在外面待一整晚，因为我没法回宿舍。那让我很烦。我总是想，他们为什么不能像正常的白人那样开派对呢？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And this is the other thing. Everybody else would be gone on their dates already. And I would be the only person left in the dorm waiting for this black party to start! Me and the black girls left in the dorm. All the white girls are gone already.
还有别的事。其他人早就去约会了，我成了宿舍里唯一一个等着这个黑人派对开始的人！就我和留在宿舍里的黑人女孩。所有白人女孩早就走了。
My mom was so white to me at that moment. Growing up, I just thought of her as my mother. But as she told me this, she seemed like the whitest white person in the world. I asked my mom how she met my father. She said they met in a cafeteria. She said Clara and her were getting lunch.
那时在我眼里，我妈看起来太“白”了。成长过程中，我一直把她当成我妈妈。但当她告诉我这些时，她看起来就像世界上最白的白人。我问我妈是怎么认识我爸的。她说他们是在食堂认识的。她说克拉拉和她当时正在买午餐。
I remember exactly how this happened. We were standing in line at the cafeteria, and Richard was so many people in front of us around the corner, like we could see him maybe 30 feet away. And I said, "Clare, I want you to introduce me to him. He is gorgeous." And he has something about his legs. Because he used to wear these faded, almost threadbare corduroys that fit him like a glove. And his muscles were so defined from track that his leg muscles would just bulge through these-- [GIGGLES]. And I wanted to meet him because of his legs. This is terrible. It was totally lust.
我清楚地记得事情是怎么发生的。我们在食堂排队，理查德在转角前面的许多人那里，就像我们能看到他，大概在30英尺外。我对克拉拉说：“克拉拉，我想让你介绍我认识他。他太迷人了。” 他腿上有种特别的地方。因为他以前总是穿那种褪色、几乎磨损的灯芯绒裤子，穿在他身上就像手套一样贴身。他的腿部肌肉因为田径训练而轮廓分明，以至于他的腿部肌肉会从那些裤子里隆起—— [咯咯笑]。我想认识他就是因为他的腿。这太糟糕了。这完全是出于欲望。
What attracted you to Mom?
什么吸引了你和你妈妈？
I think it was the times that we were going through, in terms of Martin Luther King era, in regard to looking toward being open to any race and thinking things were going to change. And then everybody was going to be accepted as anyone else.
我想是当时我们所处的时代，马丁·路德·金时代，那种对任何种族都保持开放态度，认为事情会发生改变。每个人都会像其他人一样被接纳。
That's about as far as my father goes when he talks about dating my mom. He doesn't talk about her. He talks about the openness of the '60s and the attitude of the era, as if the '60s had been dating my mom instead of him. My mom also recalls being caught up in the times.
我父亲谈到和我母亲约会时，也就只能说这么多了。他不谈论她。他谈论的是60年代的开放和那个时代的氛围，就好像是60年代在和他妈妈约会，而不是他。我妈妈也回忆起自己被那个时代所感染。
I remember very clearly believing that it was going to be a different world, and that-- you know, John F. Kennedy and then Martin Luther King-- that the world was going to change and that we wouldn't live in a racially divided country anymore. And so I had no doubt at that time that my kids would live in a totally different environment than I had grown up in, that there wouldn't be any racial prejudice when you guys were growing up.
我记得非常清楚，当时我相信世界将会变得不同——你知道，约翰·F·肯尼迪，然后是马丁·路德·金——世界将会改变，我们将不会再生活在一个种族分裂的国家。所以当时我毫不怀疑你们在成长过程中会生活在一个完全不同的环境中，不会有任何种族偏见。
Neither of my parents was an activist. They weren't trying to change the world. But clearly half the fun of finding each other was the thrill of mixing with someone of the other race. After a year of dating, my mom got pregnant and they decided to get married. The ceremony was small. Both my parents' families disapproved of the marriage. In fact, my father's sister Bernice remembers my white grandmother call my black grandmother on the phone before the wedding to propose that they form an interracial coalition to stop the marriage. Neither grandmother admits to remembering this, but neither came to the wedding either.
我父母都不是活动家。他们并不是要改变世界。但显然，找到对方的一半乐趣在于与另一种族的人交往的刺激。约会一年后，我妈怀孕了，他们决定结婚。婚礼很小。双方家庭都不赞成这门亲事。事实上，我父亲的妹妹伯尼斯还记得，婚礼前我那位白人祖母打电话给我那位黑人祖母，提议建立一个跨种族联盟来阻止这场婚姻。两位祖母都不承认记得这件事，但她们也都没参加婚礼。
Oh, this was written the night of our wedding.
哦，这是我们婚礼那天晚上写的。
"Tonight is the night, as I guess Janey has told you. We talked to Pastor Stefan Tuesday evening and decided to arrange things for this weekend since the next two weeks are going to be full of study for final exams and moving, we hope. I'm going to wear that pale blue cocktail dress, size 11, it fits me again, and a white mantilla and black patent shoes.
“今晚就是那个日子了，我想珍妮应该已经告诉你了。我们周二晚上和斯蒂芬牧师谈过，决定把事情安排在这个周末，因为接下来两周我们会忙于期末考试和搬家，我们希望如此。我要穿那件浅蓝色鸡尾酒礼服，11号的，我又穿得进了，还要戴上白色的曼蒂拉头纱，穿上黑色漆皮鞋。
Daddy, I'm sending you my tax statement. Would you rather I fill out the forms? I'm taking Personal Finance next semester which will teach me all about insurance and taxes and things like that. Have you told Grandma and Grandpa yet or Janine and Buddy? Is it all right if I write to the aunts and uncles? Whatever you want me to do is OK, but I'd rather tell everyone now. That's all for now, I guess. I'm so sorry that this is so hard for you to understand and accept. I know it will be an uphill road from now on, but we could do it. Much love, Jul."
爸爸，我给你寄了税单。你愿意我来填表吗？下学期我要修个人理财课，会学到所有关于保险和税务之类的知识。你告诉祖父母，还是珍妮和巴迪了吗？我写信给姑姨叔伯们可以吗？你想让我怎么做都行，但我现在就想告诉每个人。我想就这些了。真的很抱歉，这对你来说很难理解和接受。我知道从现在开始是一条坎坷的路，但我们能做到。深爱你们的，朱莉。”
And after I was married to him, it didn't take me very long to realize that it was going to be a fairly successful marriage because his value system was very close to mine. He's very family oriented. He came from a middle-class upbringing which valued education. And so I didn't think it was very difficult to be married to him, even though I hadn't planned to, because the things that I wanted out of a marriage, he wanted too. And just little simple things, like going to the grocery store and being able to pick out food that I knew he was going to eat. I didn't have to cook chitlins, which-- I guess it was easier than I expected. That's a stupid example.
在嫁给他之后，我没过多久就意识到这将是一段相当成功的婚姻，因为他的价值观和我很接近。他非常顾家。他出身于一个重视教育的中产阶级家庭。所以我觉得嫁给他并不是很难，即使我没计划过，因为我想要的东西，他也想要。一些简单的小事，比如去杂货店，能挑出我知道他会吃的食物。我不必做猪下水，我想，这比我预想的要容易。这例子举得挺笨的。
But I didn't have to change anything about the way I already was. Church. He went to church with me every Sunday. He fit right in. When he was in his fraternity, him and his group of fraternity friends, he was very outgoing, funny, loud-- like you are. People laughed when he made jokes. And he could sing really good. And a lot of the fraternity functions, they would have what they called a line. And he was in this little quartet with Arthur-somebody from New York. And John Brooks was in the quartet and somebody else. And they did all these little Temptation numbers where they would dance together.
但我不需要改变我现有的生活方式。去教堂。他每周日都跟我一起去。他很合群。当他在联谊会时，他和那群联谊会朋友在一起，他非常外向、风趣、大声——就像你一样。当他开玩笑时人们会笑。他歌唱得特别好。在很多联谊会活动中，他们会有所谓的走台。他和来自纽约的亚瑟什么的组成了一个四重唱。约翰·布鲁克斯也在里面。他们表演那些小诱惑合唱团的曲目，跳舞。
And so most of the time when I was with him, he was fun to be around. But what was lacking, I guess, the jump between that and getting married was that we never had any conversation. I didn't know him at all. Other than the fact that we had sex together all the time, it wasn't like you'd sit down and have long conversations getting to know each other. Because he doesn't talk. You can't get to know somebody who doesn't talk.
所以大多数时候和他在一起，他很有趣。但所缺乏的——我想，从那跳跃到结婚之间——是我们从来没有过任何谈话。我根本不了解他。除了我们一直有性生活这件事，我们不像会坐下来进行长谈去了解对方。因为他不说话。你无法了解一个不说话的人。
Bernice and Grandma said they were both surprised when he said he was getting married. And one of the reasons was, "Cause he don't talk!"
伯尼斯和祖母说，当他说他要结婚时，她们都很惊讶。其中一个原因是：“因为他不说话！”
That's right! It would be the same--
说得对！这都一样——
This is the thing about my father, he doesn't talk. Everyone in the family knows this. It's an established fact, an elemental property of my dad. My grandmother says he learned this from her.
关于我父亲的事就是，他不说话。家里每个人都知道这点。这是一个公认的事实，是我爸的一个基本属性。我祖母说他这是从她那学来的。
That's the best way. Don't you think? When you talk so much, you get in trouble.
那是最好的方式。你不觉得吗？当你话说得太多，你就会惹麻烦。
With who?
和谁？
Those think it best you don't talk so much.
那些认为你最好别说那么多的人。
Oh, yeah?
哦，是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
The long-term plan after graduation was to move to Brooklyn, back to my dad's hometown. My mother wrote home about it.
毕业后的长期计划是搬到布鲁克林，回到我爸的老家。我母亲为此写信回家。
"Robby is so excited about going back. All his friends are there and I don't think he ever wants to live anywhere else. I want to have a house in the country, but--" God, I can't believe I thought I was getting a house in the country near New York!
“罗比对回去非常兴奋。他所有的朋友都在那儿，我觉得他再也不想去别的地方住。我想在乡下有个房子，但——” 天哪，我无法相信我当时以为我能在纽约附近有个乡下房子！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Jesus!
天哪！
That's awesome.
太棒了。
"Say hi--" I'm telling you, Rich! You don't understand. I was so small-towny.
“代我向——问好” 我跟你说，里奇！你不明白。我当时太土气了。
Had you been to New York?
你去过纽约吗？
No. Obviously not.
没有。显然没有。
It turns out my dad romanticized some things too. Brooklyn had changed a lot since he grew up. Now there were bums in the park, abandoned stores, and riot gates. At the school where my dad worked, the kids were breaking windows and starting fires and attacking teachers. My dad hated that there was nowhere he felt safe letting us kids run around. And my mom hated sharing a kitchen with the cockroaches.
事实证明，我爸也把一些事情浪漫化了。布鲁克林在他长大后已经变了很多。现在公园里有流浪汉，店铺关门，装上了防暴栅栏。我父亲工作的学校里，孩子们砸窗户、纵火、袭击老师。我爸讨厌那种没有安全感、不能让我们到处跑的地方。我妈则讨厌和蟑螂共用厨房。
Their apartment was right next to the El, so it was loud and everything-- furniture, clothes, kids-- was always covered in a fine layer of soot. And they were real poor. My father's substitute teaching job barely paid the rent. In Indiana, my parents had fun together. It wasn't like that in New York. Everything was all about working and struggling to survive. Finally, someone threw a brick through their window, breaking glass all over the living room where my sister and I had been playing only a few minutes earlier.
他们的公寓就在轻轨线旁边，非常吵，所有东西——家具、衣服、孩子——总是覆盖着一层细细的煤灰。而且他们真的很穷。我父亲教代课老师的薪水几乎付不起房租。在印第安纳，我父母在一起很有趣。在纽约不是这样。一切都是为了生存而工作和挣扎。最后，有人往他们窗户里扔了一块砖头，玻璃碎了一地，而就在几分钟前，我和我妹妹还在那里玩耍。
Within a week, my parents packed up a U-Haul and drove straight back to Indiana. They lived in Brooklyn only six months.
一周之内，我父母打包了一辆U-Haul货车，直接开车回了印第安纳。他们在布鲁克林只住了六个月。
If there's a tragedy in this story, it begins here. As hard as things were in Brooklyn, I think my parents' marriage could have made it there, with my dad living in a world he was used to, surrounded by friends and family, and my mother happily exploring a different world. But Indianapolis ate away at my father. At first, it was just like he wanted. The streets were wide, clean, and empty, with trees on both sides and grass that was always greener. A canal meanders through the city.
如果这个故事里有悲剧，那便从这里开始。尽管在布鲁克林生活艰难，但我认为我父母的婚姻本可以在那维持下去。我爸生活在他习惯的世界里，被朋友和家人包围，而我母亲则乐于探索一个不同的世界。但印第安纳波利斯消磨了我父亲。起初，这正是他想要的。街道宽阔、整洁、空旷，两旁种满了树，草地总是更绿。一条运河蜿蜒穿过城市。
Indianapolis was the opposite of Brooklyn. It made parenting easy and fun. We flew kites in the summer and built snow forts in the winter. I found an old reel-to-reel tape of my father, my sister, and me in those early days.
印第安纳波利斯和布鲁克林截然相反。它让育儿变得轻松有趣。夏天我们放风筝，冬天我们造雪堡。我找到一盘旧录音带，记录了我和我父亲、妹妹在那些早期的日子里的时光。
What did we make yesterday?
昨天我们做了什么？
Snowman.
雪人。
Which one? A Mama or a Daddy snowman?
哪一个？妈妈雪人还是爸爸雪人？
Today, we made a snowman [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Today, I'll go make a Daddy snowman.
今天，我们做了个雪人 [听不清]。今天，我要去做一个爸爸雪人。
That's great. We'll make a Daddy snowman today.
太棒了。我们今天要做一个爸爸雪人。
[BABY NOISES]
[婴儿声音]
We spent Christmas that first year at my grandparents' 80-acre farm with my mother's family. Dad saw how beautiful it was there, how perfect for us kids to run around and explore. We went back for Easter and then Thanksgiving and Christmas again and every year for the next eight years. We practically had forgot about my dad's family in Brooklyn. That's how my dad's sister, Bernice, remembers it.
那年的圣诞节我们是在我外祖父母的80英亩农场度过的。爸爸看到了那里有多美，多适合我们这些孩子到处奔跑探索。接下来八年，我们每年回去过复活节，然后感恩节、圣诞节。我们几乎忘了布鲁克林的父系亲属。我父亲的妹妹伯尼斯就是这么记得的。
And we didn't see Richard again for about 10 years. The only thing we knew is-- we called every now and then. And we knew that he had moved into a trailer and he had bought a house and then he sold that house and he was somewhere else. We just kind of casually kept in contact with him. And that was it. We'd get a Christmas card. And maybe once a year, we'd get a phone call. That was it. He was completely detached from the family.
然后我们大约10年没见到理查德了。我们所知道的只是——我们偶尔打电话。我们知道他搬进了一个拖车里，后来买了栋房子，又卖了那栋房子，然后去了别的地方。我们只是随随便便和他保持联系。就这样。我们会收到圣诞贺卡。也许一年会有一次电话。就这样。他完全脱离了家庭。
In this new world, no one was black except my father. He never saw his family, he didn't make any friends, he didn't keep in touch with his old college friends. I asked my dad who he hung out with in Indiana when my parents were married.
在这个新世界里，除了我父亲，没有人是黑人。他从不见他的家人，他不交朋友，也不和大学的老朋友联系。我问我爸，在印第安纳的时候，我和妈妈结婚时，他都和谁混在一起。
I don't know whether you'd say hang out. There was occasions that you'd go to in terms of gatherings, but I didn't hang out with anyone.
我不知道你会不会说那是混在一起。有时候会参加一些聚会，但我没和任何人混在一起。
Huh. Who hung out with your friends?
嗯。谁和你朋友混在一起？
I had things to do. I was pretty much on my own or pretty much an entity within myself. It was just mainly children, my children. It wasn't many friends at all.
我有事情要做。我基本上是靠自己，或者说是作为一个独立的个体。基本上只有孩子，我的孩子。根本没几个朋友。
I used to think then, I used to think it was very sad. I remember feeling this way. The few times that we went back to New York, he would flip into a whole alter person, second person-- like a schizophrenic personality, a totally different person. We'd go to New York. He'd be hanging out with Poke, laughing. His brother, laughing. His sister, laughing. Drinking a lot, partying, just like I remembered him in college before we got married.
我以前那时总觉得，我觉得这非常可悲。我记得那种感觉。那仅有的几次我们回纽约，他会变成完全另一个人，第二人格——就像精神分裂一样，完全不同的人。我们回纽约。他会和波克混在一起，大笑。他的兄弟，大笑。他的姐妹，大笑。喝很多酒，参加派对，就像我记忆中结婚前在大学里的他。
It was like all of a sudden, we're back in this fraternity party mode again, real easy about everything, never uptight, never with this, you know the stand that he does with his hands across his chest where he looks like he's holding everything in, being tough? He never stands like that in New York. And so he was just back to his normal self. And then we'd come back to Indiana and he'd go back into this person again, like he was this black man living in this white world kind of thing, that he wasn't himself.
就像突然之间，他又回到了那种联谊会派对模式，对任何事都很放松，从不紧张，从来没有这种，你知道他那种把手交叉在胸前，看起来就像是在强忍一切、表现得强硬的样子？他在纽约从来不那样站着。所以他恢复了正常的自我。然后我们回到印第安纳，他又变回了那个人，就像一个生活在白人世界的黑人，他不像是他自己。
Your dad never took me to a black function. Everything we did was in my world. So I don't think that was fair. I didn't marry into that.
你爸从没带我参加过黑人的活动。我们做的一切都在我的世界里。所以我觉得那不公平。我嫁的不是那种生活。
When I was dating him, the thing I liked about him was that I was living in another culture environment. You have to understand, I'm a foreign language major. I like cultures. It's important to me. So he kind of deprived me, or our marriage I think, of that cultural experience because he didn't contribute to it.
当我跟他约会时，我喜欢他的一点是我生活在另一种文化环境中。你要明白，我是外语专业的。我喜欢文化。这对我很重要。所以我认为他剥夺了我的，或者说我们婚姻的，那种文化体验，因为他没有为此做出贡献。
My father became someone else in Indiana, a completely different person. And this new face he put on is the face that I recognize and that I picture when I think about him. I can't imagine my father dancing and drinking or laughing with a posse of black friends. My father is someone who never took a sick day from work, who was always home and always responsible. He is a withdrawn and lonely father of three in a white city.
我父亲在印第安纳变成了另一个人，一个完全不同的人。而他戴上的这张新面孔，就是我认得的那张，也是我想到他时脑海中出现的。我无法想象我父亲和一群黑人朋友跳舞、喝酒或大笑。我父亲是一个从不因生病请假缺席工作的人，他总是待在家里，总是负责任。他是三个孩子中一个沉默寡言、孤独的父亲，生活在白人城市。
No, it didn't pan out that well for myself. No, I didn't have much of anything. I just kind of walked away from all I knew and everything that was a part of me. If there was a personality change, it might have been as a result of that.
不，那对我自己来说并没有那么好。不，我没剩下什么东西。我只是离开了所有我认识的、所有我生命一部分的东西。如果说有性格改变，那可能是那样的结果。
So how did you survive?
那你怎么挺过来的？
Well, I didn't think about. I just worked and raised the children. At the time, that was what was important.
嗯，我没去想那个。我只是工作，抚养孩子。在那时，那才是最重要的。
I stood face to face in a doorway with my father talking about this for an hour. Neither of us moved. Neither of us sat down. And as we unearthed this, I felt sorry for him and I understood why he had become who he was. It wasn't exactly that race destroyed their marriage, but it added to his isolation and subtracted from his person. And that, in the end, destroyed what they had together.
我面对面站在门口，跟我父亲谈论这个谈了一个小时。我们谁都没动。我们都没坐下。当我挖掘这些时，我为他感到难过，也理解了他为什么变成了现在这样。并不是说种族摧毁了他们的婚姻，但它增加了他的孤立感，减少了他的自我。而最终，这摧毁了他们在一起拥有的一切。
Before I started doing this story, I never talked to my parents about how their marriage failed or what their divorce was supposed to mean for me, expressly about who I choose to marry or not marry. Getting my dad to sit down for one last round of questions about this wasn't easy.
在开始做这个故事之前，我从没跟我父母谈论过他们的婚姻为何失败，或者他们的离婚对我来说意味着什么，特别是在我选择娶谁或不娶谁的问题上。让爸爸坐下来就此进行最后一轮提问并不容易。
You have to talk to me. Do you know what my story is, Dad?
你必须跟我谈谈。你知道我的故事是什么吗，爸爸？
Well, I'll talk, but I don't want to talk forever and ever.
嗯，我会说，但我不想没完没了地说。
Well, let me ask you if  you know what my-- do you know what I'm doing a story on? I'm doing a story on my parents. You and Mom. I'm trying to use-- I mean, I'm not saying I'm using you as an example in my life, but I'm trying to get a message from you on what I should do, because you never, I don't know. You never say anything. So I'm just trying to figure it out.
嗯，让我问问你知不知道——你知道我在写什么故事吗？我在写关于我父母的故事。你和妈妈。我正试着利用——我的意思是，我不是说我在用你们作为我人生的例子，但我正试图从你们那里得到一个关于我该怎么做的建议，因为你从不，我不知道。你从不说任何话。所以我只是想弄清楚。
And here's what I see. You got married to a white woman, in whatever, '67. You guys got divorced, and all of a sudden, you're over here in a completely-- now, you're in an all-black world, right?
这是我看到的。你和白人女性结婚，不管是什么时候，67年吧。你们离婚了，突然之间，你就在这儿，完全——现在，你在一个全黑人的世界里，对吗？
Well, I work with white teachers.
嗯，我和白人老师一起工作。
Well, all your friends, your family. You're happy now. And she's over there in an all-white world. I mean, is that a lesson?
嗯，你所有的朋友，你的家人。你现在很快乐。而她在那里生活在一个全白人的世界里。我的意思是，这是一个教训吗？
I do think it's very important not to go into something-- marriage, as you're saying, as you asked me about mixed situation-- if you're very, very young.
我认为在某些方面不要操之过急很重要——婚姻，正如你所说，正如你问我的混合情况——如果你还非常、非常年轻的话。
Well, what about if you're old?
嗯，如果你老了呢？
If you're older and you've got your structure, you've got your friends, in terms of--
如果你年龄大一点，有了你的基础，有了你的朋友，就——
So you don't think it's a mistake at all.
所以你根本不觉得这是个错误。
I think you can do all right. And where you live is still kind of important, in terms of the state. If a person were in New York or perhaps even California-- and there's probably other places that I don't know about, then it doesn't really matter what.
我想你可以做得很好。而且你住的地方还是有点重要的，就州而言。如果一个人在纽约，或者甚至可能是加利福尼亚——可能还有我不了解的地方，那么是什么并不重要。
This is not the answer I expected from him. He thinks intermarriage can work so long as you're not isolated from your own race the way he was in Indiana. It's not the answer I wanted.
这不是我预期的答案。他认为跨种族婚姻可以奏效，只要你不像他在印第安纳那样被孤立于自己的种族之外就行。这不是我想要的答案。
You know what my-- I have this Asian friend. Girlfriend. Well, friend-girl. You know what she said to me about mixed marriages? She said, you can never marry a white girl because she'll never understand.
你知道我的——我有一个亚洲女性朋友。女朋友。嗯，女性朋友。你知道她对我说了什么关于混合婚姻吗？她说，你永远不能娶一个白人女孩，因为她永远不会理解。
Well, I don't know what there is in back of that thought, in terms of what she's saying, other than if she's saying that they'll never understand where you're coming from in terms of your history, or something like that, if you haven't felt it, tasted it, lived it, I don't know. So some things will probably go beyond explanation. You just know. If you have to start explaining this, it don't work. Impossible.
嗯，我不知道她这么想的背后有什么，就她所说的而言，除非她是说她们永远不会理解你作为一个人，就你的历史而言是来自哪里，或者类似的事，如果你没感受到、没尝过、没活过，我不知道。所以有些事可能超出了语言所能解释的范围。你就是知道。如果你非得开始解释这个，那就行不通。不可能。
His answer is sort of ambiguous, but the way I take this, and the way I want to take this, is that he agrees with me, that a white woman will never understand.
他的回答有些模糊，但我理解这一点，我想要理解的，是他同意我的观点，即白人女性永远不会理解。
Did Mom ever understand?
妈妈曾理解过吗？
I don't know if I could say she understood or not understood. But I think that she is a product of her upbringing. And I am a product of my upbringing. And that doesn't mean it's bad, but it is somewhat different.
我不知道我能否说她理解或不理解。但我认为她是她教养的产物。而我是我教养的产物。那并不意味着是坏事，但确实有所不同。
Again, his answer is blurry, but that's just the way he talks. I'm pretty sure what he's saying is that she didn't understand. My mom disagrees completely. When I call her up to talk about this, I tell her that the lesson I take from their divorce is that interracial marriage doesn't work.
同样，他的回答很模糊，但他说话就是这样。我很确定他说的是她不理解。我妈完全不同意。当我打电话给她谈论这个时，我告诉她，我从他们的离婚中吸取的教训是跨种族婚姻行不通。
Would I agree with that? No. Not at all. No, I really don't think that it had anything to do with race. I think it had to do with other things. I always thought that our marriage was like anybody else's marriage. You talk about the same things. You talk about money or your kids or what you're going to do on the weekend or whatever. The color of skin was the only thing that was different. But the falling apart had nothing to do with that, I don't think. At least not from my point of view. It may have from your dad's. But it didn't for me at all.
我会同意吗？不。根本不是。不，我真的不认为这和种族有任何关系。我认为这和别的事情有关。我一直认为我们的婚姻和别人的婚姻没什么不同。你们讨论同样的事情。讨论钱、孩子，周末要做什么，诸如此类。肤色是唯一不同的东西。但我认为分崩离析和那无关。至少从我的角度看是这样。对你爸来说可能有关。但对我来说完全没有。
Well, since college, I kind of changed my opinion. I don't think I'm ever going to-- I don't think I'm going to marry white. And one of my friends was telling me, and she kind of gave me the good reason in my head, she said, "You can never marry a white woman because she'll never understand."
嗯，从大学开始，我改变了我的观点。我不认为我永远会——我不认为我会娶白人。我的一个朋友告诉我，她在我的脑海中给出了充分的理由，她说：“你永远不能娶白人女性，因为她永远不会理解。”
Well, that's probably true. I'm not going to be upset if you marry a black girl, for sure. I don't care one way or the other, as long as you're happy. These are issues like religion. Everybody has their own personal feeling about it, and you don't have to agree.
嗯，那可能是真的。如果我娶个黑人女孩，我也绝对不会难过。我不在乎，只要你快乐。这些问题就像宗教一样。每个人都有自己的个人感受，你不需要同意。
I ask my mom what I asked my dad, if she thinks a white woman can understand a black man, specifically me.
我问我妈同样的问题，问她是否认为白人女性能理解黑人男性，具体来说就是我。
If you are open I think they can. When people get married to each other, they're supposed to be intimate with all of their thoughts. And if you are, then you can understand another person. I don't think the race gets in the way of that.
如果你是开放的，我认为她们可以。当人们结婚时，他们应该与对方分享所有的想法。如果你做到了，那么你就能理解另一个人。我不认为种族会阻碍这一点。
Well, why do you think it makes a difference to me then?
那么为什么你认为对我来说有什么区别呢？
Maybe you're more conscious of it because you're neither.
也许你更在意它，因为你两者都不是。
It's not true.
那不是真的。
I don't know. Do you feel uncomfortable in both worlds in a way?
我不知道。你是否在某种程度上觉得在两个世界里都不舒服？
Yeah. And I don't really want to lose either part.
是啊。而且我真的不想失去任何一部分。
Well, that's one of those human dilemmas. You just have to work on it for the rest of your life.
嗯，那是人类的困境之一。你必须在余生中去解决它。
Here's what I figured out doing this story. I still can't imagine marrying a white woman, but not because I believe race destroyed my parents' marriage. I don't really believe that anymore. but because I realize I'm used to crossing between two worlds, and I want someone who can do that with me. And for better or worse, right or wrong, I just can't imagine having a blond-haired, blue-eyed girlfriend standing next to me at the Black Poets Society.
这就是我做这个故事发现的东西。我仍然无法想象娶一个白人女性，但不是因为我相信种族摧毁了我父母的婚姻。我不再真正相信那个了。而是因为我意识到我习惯于在两个世界之间穿梭，我想要一个能和我一起做到这一点的人。而且无论好坏、无论对错，我就是无法想象有一个金发碧眼的白人女友站在黑人诗人协会的现场陪着我。
As for my parents, my mom says she barely knows any black people anymore. And with each passing decade, she says, her world has gotten whiter. Meanwhile, my father's going to dances again put on by the Kappas, the same fraternity that threw most of the parties while he was in college. But this time, when Marvin Gaye comes on, the woman he's dancing with is black instead of white. And I can picture him later in the night off in some corner of the room singing "My Girl" in a line with his brothers.
至于我父母，我妈说她现在几乎不认识什么黑人了。她说，每过十年，她的世界就变得越白。与此同时，我父亲又开始参加由卡帕会举办的舞会了，那是他大学时举行过大多数派对的联谊会。但这一次，当马文·盖的歌响起时，和他跳舞的女人是黑人，而不是白人。我可以想象他深夜在房间的某个角落，和他的兄弟们排成一列唱着《我的女孩》。
Rich Robinson in New York City. The number of interracial marriages in the United States was 1.1 million couples in the 1990 census. That's three times more than in 1970, but still less than 2% of all marriages.
纽约市的里奇·罗宾逊。根据1990年的人口普查，美国有110万对跨种族婚姻夫妇。这是1970年的三倍，但仍不到所有婚姻的2%。
[MUSIC - "DON'T BE AFRAID OF LOVE" BY OTIS REDDING]
[音乐 - 奥蒂斯·雷丁的《别害怕爱情》]
Coming up, another person attempts to do what drove fear in the hearts of segregationists not that long ago. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，另一个人试图做一件在不久前还让种族隔离主义者心惊胆战的事。来自国际公共广播电台，节目将在片刻后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today's program, Bring a Negro Boy Home Tonight. And if that seems like a strange title, then you're just going to have to start listening to these shows from the beginning. The show is stories of people defying some of the oldest codes of behavior in our country by mixing races. Act One of our show was about intermarriage. Act Two is about economic integration, about trying to make the leap from one of the poorest neighborhoods in the country to where our nation's richest people live.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“今晚带个黑人男孩回家”。如果这听起来像是一个奇怪的题目，那你只能从头开始听这些节目了。这档节目讲述的是人们通过混血，挑战我们国家一些最古老的行为准则的故事。我们节目的第一幕是关于跨种族婚姻。第二幕是关于经济融合，关于试图从全国最贫穷的社区之一，跨越到我们国家最富有的人生活的地方。
Cedric Jennings went to Ballou High School in a poor, black neighborhood in Southeast Washington. It was the kind of school where honor students do not like it to be known that they're honor students. There aren't many of them, and when they spot their names posted on the big honor roll bulletin board by the main office, they would rush, some of them, to ask to be taken off. When administrators wanted to hold an assembly to give out academic awards, they would keep the purpose of the assembly secret even from the teachers because the teachers would then leak the information to the honor students who would then simply not show up.
塞德里克·詹宁斯在华盛顿东南部的一个贫穷的黑人社区巴洛高中上学。那是一所荣誉学生不喜欢让别人知道自己是荣誉学生的学校。那样的人不多，当他们发现自己的名字贴在主办公室旁边的大公告栏上时，他们中的一些人会冲过去要求被撤下来。当校方想要举行集会颁发学术奖项时，他们甚至会瞒着老师，因为老师们会把消息泄露给荣誉学生，而荣誉学生随后就会干脆不露面。
Well, although I was really proud of my accomplishments, I didn't want to actually see my peers respond to me in a negative way so I just avoided the assembly.
嗯，虽然我为自己的成就感到自豪，但我不想真的看到同伴们以消极的方式回应我，所以我只是避开了集会。
Honor students at his high school were teased. They were called whitey. They were ostracized. They were threatened with physical violence. As an honor student, Cedric was constantly taunted. He ate lunch alone in an empty classroom. He went to church, never socialized with other kids, fearing it would make him lose focus.
他那所高中的荣誉学生会被嘲笑。他们被称为“白皮”。他们被排斥。他们受到暴力威胁。作为一名荣誉学生，塞德里克不断受到奚落。他在空教室里独自吃午饭。他去教堂，从不和别的孩子社交，害怕那样会让他失去专注力。
When a person says that they want to be successful, they have to realize that there will be opposition. And despite what opposition says, when someone says you can't, I had this defiant side of myself. When I said, oh, I can't? No, I think I can.
当一个人说他想成功时，必须意识到会有阻力。尽管阻力怎么说，当有人说你不行时，我内心有种反抗的一面。当我对自己说，哦，我不行？不，我想我能行。
Cedric bet everything in his life as a teenager on the hope that he would get a scholarship to a top college. Reporter Ron Suskind started following him around when Cedric was just 16. He stayed with him for two and a half years, published stories about him in The Wall Street Journal which won a Pulitzer Prize. Cedric's first serious encounter with the elite universities that he wanted to enter came after his junior year in that summer, a summer program at the Massachusetts Institute of Technology, a program designed to attract minority students to MIT. The program was called MITES, M-I-T-E-S, the Minority Introduction To Engineering and Science, 50-some kids who supposedly came from neighborhoods like Cedric's.
作为一个少年，塞德里克拿自己生活中的一切打赌，希望自己能获得顶尖大学的奖学金。记者罗恩·萨斯金德在塞德里克16岁时就开始跟踪报道他。他跟随了他两年半，在《华尔街日报》上发表了关于他的文章，并赢得了普利策奖。塞德里克第一次与他想进入的精英大学进行严肃接触，是在他高三那年的夏天，那是麻省理工学院的一个暑期项目，一个旨在吸引少数族裔学生进入MIT的项目。该项目被称为MITES，即“少数族裔科学与工程导论”，有50多个据说是来自像塞德里克这种社区的孩子。
Making it into the program was Cedric's dream. It was the first foothold in this new world he was trying to enter into. But when classes began, Cedric found that he could barely keep up. And even worse, he was just as isolated at MIT as he'd been back at Ballou. Calculus, physics, chemistry were are filled with kids from middle-class backgrounds, good suburban schools, private schools. Some of them had seen this material before back home.
进入这个项目是塞德里克的梦想。这是他试图进入这个新世界的第一块立足点。但当课程开始时，塞德里克发现自己几乎跟不上。更糟糕的是，他在麻省理工学院感到孤立，就像在巴洛高中一样。微积分、物理、化学课上满是中产阶级背景的孩子、优秀的郊区学校和私立学校的学生。他们中的一些人在老家时就见过这些材料。
It was really a disappointment. And it sort of made me feel inadequate during the process, when I'm taking all the notes and they're just nodding their heads like, oh, yeah. OK.
这真是个失望。而且在这个过程中，当我记着所有的笔记，而他们只是点头，仿佛“哦，是的，好吧”时，这让我感到自己很无能。
Oh, yeah. That one. Seen that one.
哦，是的。那个。见过那个。
Yeah, I've heard that before.
是的，我以前听过那个。
And we should say that at your high school back in Washington, in the public school, you were in the most advanced classes they offered.
我们要说的是，在你华盛顿的老家高中，在公立学校里，你上的是他们提供的最高级的课程。
Right. And even in the most advanced classes they offered, I had done above and beyond. So I thought that that would be enough to prepare me. And I guess it wasn't.
对。即使在他们提供的最高级课程中，我也超额完成了。所以我以为那足以让我做好准备。我想并没有。
There's this moment in this part of the story which is just completely heartbreaking to read where you get back your first test and you get a 4 out of 26 in your physics class.
在故事的这一部分有一个瞬间，读起来简直让人心碎，你拿回了第一次考试成绩，你的物理课成绩是26分之4。
So bad.
太糟糕了。
And a 68 out of 104 in calculus. And you're a student who's used to getting all A's, ends up being the star of every class.
微积分成绩是104分之68。而你是一个习惯于拿全A，最终成为每门课明星的学生。
Well, it was a learning experience. It was disappointing, first of all. Physics was just ridiculous. I thought I was just going to go crazy. And I thought I was just going to go crazy. In physics, 4 out of 26. That is just ridiculous. There was nothing that anyone could say to make me feel better about that.
嗯，这是一种学习经历。首先，这令人失望。物理简直太离谱了。我想我当时快疯了。在物理课上，26分之4。那简直离谱。没什么人能说些什么让我觉得好受些。
Ron, let me ask you to talk a little bit about why the MIT program was set up in this way. At one point, you met with Bill Ramsey, the 68-year-old African American who heads this program to get minorities into MIT. And he talked to you about why so many suburban kids were in the program and so few city kids.
罗恩，让我请你谈谈麻省理工学院的这个项目为什么要这样设置。有一次，你见了68岁的非裔美国人比尔·拉姆齐，他负责这个让少数族裔进入麻省理工学院的项目。他和你谈到了为什么项目中会有这么多郊区孩子，而城市孩子却这么少。
Ramsey was a great guy who had been an MIT grad in 1951, when there were almost no blacks at MIT. And he was hopeful for better. He wanted what I think is the bigger and, in some ways, more important thing to occur in this MIT program when he took it over seven or eight years before Cedric got there. He wanted kids like Cedric, 50 kids like Cedric instead of one or two.
拉姆齐是个很棒的人，他在1951年毕业于麻省理工学院，那时那里几乎没有黑人。他希望情况能更好。他接手这个项目是在塞德里克进入的前七八年，他想要实现我认为更宏大、在某些方面更重要的事情。他想要像塞德里克这样的孩子，50个像塞德里克的孩子，而不是一两个。
And what he realized early on is that it would run into all manner of dilemmas that go right to the core of some of the problems with the notion of Affirmative Action. MIT sponsors the program. MIT wants as many of these kids as possible to eventually end up in their freshman class to make that freshman class look like a rainbow, as they say.
他很早就意识到，这会遇到各种各样的困境，直接指向“平权法案”概念中一些问题的核心。麻省理工学院赞助了这个项目。麻省理工学院希望尽可能多的孩子最终能进入他们的新生班级，让那个新生班级看起来像他们所说的“彩虹”。
And as people might mention, you can make the Ivy League, or any great college, look like a rainbow nowadays without ever having to go to the ghetto. You don't have to go there. There are plenty of middle and upper-middle-class black and Latino kids to fill those programs, kids who will eventually succeed at a top university. It's the other kids, kids like Cedric, for whom the distance is so vast to travel that for them, the failure rate is untenable for a place like MIT.
正如人们提到的，你现在可以让常春藤盟校，或任何伟大的大学看起来像彩虹，而无需走进贫民窟。你不需要去那里。有足够的黑人和拉丁裔中产及中上产阶级孩子填满那些项目，那些最终会在顶尖大学取得成功的孩子。而对于其他孩子，像塞德里克这样的孩子，距离太过遥远，对于像麻省理工这样的地方来说，他们的失败率是无法承受的。
Just reading your account of it, it seems like part of his concern too was that kids would come in without any preparation, or without enough preparation, to go as fast as MIT would want them to go. And then MIT had no infrastructure to bring them up to speed. And so it was just setting them up for failure.
仅阅读你对这件事的记述，似乎他担心的部分也是，孩子们会没有任何准备，或者没有足够的准备，无法像麻省理工想要的那样去学习。而麻省理工没有任何基础设施来帮助他们跟上。所以这只会让他们走向失败。
Absolutely. And they often have very big dreams, and they often come pushed forward by a whole community for whom they're the one who's going to make it. And that's a pretty heavy burden to carry to a place like MIT and then have all of that come crashing down on their head. Look, as Ramsey said, he said, look, the suicide rates up here are high enough as they are.
绝对。而且他们通常有很大的梦想，通常在整个社区的推动下前进，因为他们是那个“能成功”的人。带着这个重担来到像麻省理工这样的地方，然后眼睁睁看着这一切在头顶崩溃，是很沉重的。听着，就像拉姆齐说的，他说，听着，这里的自杀率本来就已经够高了。
So Cedric, at the end of your time with MIT, you're informed that you weren't ready for MIT just yet. And you headed back to DC and put in a lot more work and a lot more effort. And after you graduated from high school, you end up at an Ivy League school, Brown University. And let me ask you to describe, first of all, who your roommate was and what he was like. What was his background?
所以塞德里克，在你麻省理工课程结束时，你被告知还没准备好进入麻省理工。你回到了华盛顿，投入了更多的工作和努力。高中毕业后，你进入了一所常春藤盟校，布朗大学。我想请你先描述一下，你的室友是谁，他是个什么样的人？他的背景是什么？
My roommate's name was Robert and he was from Marblehead, Massachusetts. And he was a white guy. He was cool. I think both his parents were doctors.
我室友的名字叫罗伯特，他来自马萨诸塞州的马布尔黑德。他是个白人。他很酷。我想他父母都是医生。
He went to private school.
他上的是私立学校。
He went to a private school. What else? He had a sister that went to Harvard. But I think for the most part, we did get along. And I think that because we came from different backgrounds, that's where a little bit of the conflict came in. I think he came from a home where I think his mom pretty much waited on him hand and foot. And I came from a home where I was pretty much independent. I had to do things for myself, cook for myself, was for myself, those sorts of things, clean up behind myself.
他上的是私立学校。还有什么？他有一个妹妹上了哈佛。但我认为大多数时候，我们相处得还可以。而且我认为因为我们来自不同的背景，所以产生了一些冲突。我想他来自一个母亲几乎事无巨细照顾他的家庭。而我来自一个基本上很独立的家庭。我不得不为自己做事，自己做饭，洗衣服，打扫卫生。
And one of the problems that we had was that he was at times, we were both messy at times, especially with me, especially when there was a lot of work. But for the most part, there were times when he would get really, really, really messy and outrageous and just be funky, so to speak.
我们遇到的问题之一是，他有时——我们有时都很乱，特别是对我来说，尤其是工作量很大时。但大多数时候，有些时候他会变得非常、非常、非常乱，简直不可理喻，说得难听点就是有点臭。
This reminded me of when I've been in Chicago high schools, how you'll see the white kids, the way they'll keep their clothes is they'll just dress like whatever and they'll look kind of bummy. Whereas the black kids, again, it's like everything always has to be neat and perfect. And even your clothes have to be just so perfect all the time. It's like they're from two different countries.
这让我想起我在芝加哥高中时，你会看到白人孩子，他们保持衣服的方式就是随便穿，看起来有点流浪汉的感觉。而黑人孩子，同样，就像一切总是需要整洁完美。即使是你的衣服也必须总是那么完美。他们就像来自两个不同的国家。
This is true, but it's one thing if your clothes just look bad and then if your body just stinks. That's just a whole nother thing. And I think that sometimes he just was funky, man. And that's just not something that I wanted to put up with. And I wasn't willing to put up with that. There just was not much communication between us.
确实如此，但衣服看起来不好是一回事，如果你的身体臭气熏天又是另一回事。那是完全不同的另一回事。而且我觉得有时他就是很臭，伙计。那不是我愿意忍受的事情。我也不愿忍受。我们之间真的没多少交流。
Ira, they just had utterly distinct ways of doing everything. Cedric's general heightened hygiene of having grown up in often squalid places, where Cedric was cleaning all the time. Cedric was always careful about how he looked and that he himself and his person was very clean. It was the opposite from Rob who never worried. This was just one of 1,000 things like that that immediately gripped the two of them in the room until the point where they almost came to blows.
艾拉，他们做每件事的方式都截然不同。塞德里克的总体卫生标准极高，因为他成长在经常肮脏的地方，所以他总是在打扫。塞德里克总是很注意自己的外表，并且他自己和身体非常干净。这与罗伯完全相反，罗伯从不担心这些。这就是让房间里的两人立即陷入僵局的一千件事中的一件，直到他们几乎大打出手。
And Cedric, there were times that you were really isolated there.
塞德里克，确实有几次你在那里感到非常孤立。
Yeah, at Brown? Yeah. I think especially in the social arena. I grew up in church and everything. And just putting myself out there and getting involved, it went against some of what I was taught from church.
是的，在布朗？是的。我想特别是在社交领域。我在教堂长大，诸如此类。我强迫自己去社交和参与，但这违背了我从教堂学到的一些东西。
Can I ask, when's the first time you actually drank?
我可以问问，你第一次真正喝酒是什么时候吗？
I've never drank.
我从来没喝过酒。
You still have never had a beer at college?
你在大学里还没喝过啤酒？
No. Now, no.
不。现在，没有。
But the thing, Ira, if you go into Cedric's church and you go into Cedric's environment, the only reason Cedric has got where he got is because he didn't taste of any of the plates at the buffet table of adolescent life in Southeast. Most of those plates are poisoned.
但艾拉，如果你走进塞德里克的教堂，走进塞德里克的环境，塞德里克之所以能走到今天，唯一的原因就是他没有品尝过青少年生活中自助餐桌上的任何盘子。那些盘子里大多是有毒的。
Ron, let me ask you to read from page 197 in your book. At one point, you talk about just this clash of cultures.
罗恩，让我请你读读你书里的第197页。有一次，你谈到了这种文化的碰撞。
OK. "Clearly, some East Andrews residents are spending serious time and energy having fun. Despite Brown's self consciousness about each student's individuality, the four preferred pastimes are the same here as they are at almost every other college-- drink beer, smoke pot, dance to deafening music until you drop, and on the rare occasion, get naked with some other warm body.
好的。“显然，一些东安德鲁斯居民在玩乐上花费了大量的时间和精力。尽管布朗大学对每个学生的个性非常自知，但在这里最受欢迎的四种消遣和在几乎其他所有大学一样——喝啤酒、抽大麻、随着震耳欲聋的音乐跳舞直到精疲力竭，在极少数情况下，与别的温暖身体坦诚相待。”
Possibly the best explanation why Cedric Jennings is in Brown's class of 1999 is that he managed to steer clear of the buffet table of adolescent experimentation, believing rightly, it turns out, that in his neighborhood, most of those dishes were poisoned. This was an extraordinary feat, considering how peer pressure at Ballou was backed up by violence. And the almost irresistible urge for teenagers to salve deep despair with sex, drugs, and music.
也许塞德里克·詹宁斯为什么能在布朗大学1999级最好的解释就是，他成功地远离了青少年实验的自助餐桌，并且他认为是对的，因为在他所在的社区，那些盘子里大多是有毒的。考虑到巴洛高中的同伴压力是如何被暴力支持的，以及青少年为了缓解深度绝望而求助于性、毒品和音乐的那种几乎无法抗拒的冲动，这是一项非凡的壮举。
Cedric knows all this, just as he knows his resistance was made possible back when by his mother's fierce code. But eventually, something else took root. Cedric, needing to justify his monkish routine in high school night after night, developed a genuine belief that sacrifice, hard work, and extremely clean living would lead to rewards, including a scholarship to a top college. But now that he's made it, the guideposts are gone. And all around him, smart kids are getting high, getting drunk, and screwing. Even the real smart ones, kids who can eat Cedric's lunch in almost any subject.
塞德里克知道这一切，就像他知道他的抵抗是因为母亲严苛的准则才成为可能一样。但最终，别的东西扎下了根。塞德里克需要为他高中日复一日那种苦行僧般的作息寻找合理性，从而产生了一种真正的信念，即牺牲、努力工作和极其干净的生活方式会带来回报，包括获得顶尖大学的奖学金。但现在他成功了，导向牌却消失了。他周围聪明的孩子都在吸毒、喝醉、鬼混。即使是真正聪明的人，那些在几乎任何学科都能把塞德里克比下去的孩子。
Sitting alone on his bed one Saturday night, there's a knock on the door, and a few kids from down the hall crowd in, rosy with anticipation of a night of some drinking, an off-campus party one of them has heard about, and then, who knows, maybe some late-night pizza. 'Hey Cedric, come on,' one of them says.
周六晚上独自坐在床上，有人敲门，走廊里几个孩子涌了进来，脸上带着对晚上喝酒的期待，他们听说有一个校外派对，然后，谁知道呢，也许还有深夜披萨。“嘿塞德里克，来吧，” 其中一个人说。
'Naw,' Cedric says, declining nicely, trying to show he appreciates their asking. 'I just don't do that kind of stuff.' And everyone nods meaningfully, though Cedric can tell they don't really understand. In a moment, they're gone. Just as well, he thinks, half-meaning it. I can't change now."
“不，” 塞德里克说，礼貌地拒绝，试图表达他对邀请的感激。“我就是不做那种事。” 大家意味深长地点点头，尽管塞德里克看得出他们并不真正理解。过了一会儿，他们走了。他想，也好，虽然他只有一半是真心的。“我现在无法改变。”
Cedric, in your view, do you feel like the biggest difference between yourself and the people who you were meeting at Brown, do you think it was racial, or do you think it had more to do with class?
塞德里克，在你看来，你觉得你和在布朗大学遇到的那些人之间最大的区别是种族问题，还是你觉得这更多和阶级有关？
I think it had more to do with class. I mean, obviously race. I was among a few minorities. But obviously class.
我觉得这更多和阶级有关。我的意思是，当然有种族因素。我是为数不多的少数族裔之一。但显然是阶级问题。
Explain that more.
详细解释一下。
Even within a minority community, most of my peers in the minority community had gone to private schools. They were pretty much from middle-class, upper-class homes. Mothers and fathers, who were both college educated in a lot of cases, were both living at home with them. It was just totally the opposite of where I had come from. And in a lot of ways, I just felt isolated all over again, like being at MIT.
即使在少数族裔社区内，我在少数族裔社区的大多数同伴都是上私立学校的。他们基本上来自中产阶级、上层阶级的家庭。父母双方在许多情况下都有大学学历，都和他们住在家里。这和我出身的地方完全相反。在很多方面，我感觉又一次被孤立了，就像在麻省理工一样。
Did you find in any way it was easier to be close to black kids from middle-class homes than it was to be close to white kids from middle-class homes?
你有没有发现，和来自中产家庭的黑人孩子亲近，比和来自中产家庭的白人孩子亲近要更容易些？
Yeah.
是的。
There actually was a difference?
真的有区别吗？
Yeah. We had more in common. We had more in common. We were working toward the same thing, pretty much.
是的。我们有更多共同点。我们有更多共同点。我们都在朝着同一个目标努力，差不多。
It's interesting thinking about this in terms of just the history of integration. Putting together this show, I was talking to one of my producers, and we were talking about how towards the end of Dr. King's life, one of the things that he looked at and started to think about was the question of OK, now under the law, blacks can go anywhere. But moving towards economic integration, moving people out of poor neighborhoods and up into the middle class seems so much more difficult. And reading the account of you at Brown trying to make that class jump just reiterates how hard it is.
想到这真有趣，就融合的历史而言。在筹备这个节目时，我和我的一个制片人聊天，我们谈到在马丁·路德·金博士生命的最后阶段，他审视并开始思考的一件事是：好吧，现在在法律上，黑人可以去任何地方了。但转向经济融合，让人们搬出贫民窟并进入中产阶级似乎困难得多。而读到你试图在布朗大学完成阶级跨越的记录，再次重申了这件事有多么困难。
It's extremely hard. It's hard to see with my mother and everything. At first, I must admit I was a little ashamed of her coming to Brown because I knew that she was not like any of the other parents in terms of what we had. I mean, when I look back on it, I actually was ashamed because I knew that the other parents, they had a lot of advantages and they had things in life. And a lot of them had it easy. They got it easy.
这极其困难。这很难和我的母亲以及其他一切联系起来看。起初，我必须承认，我对我母亲来布朗大学感到有点羞耻，因为我知道我们所拥有的东西和别的家长的完全不同。我的意思是，当我回首往事时，我其实感到羞耻，因为我知道别的家长，他们有很多优势，生活中什么都有。他们中很多人都很轻松。他们得到的很容易。
And my mother, we come from welfare. She's on welfare. She had dropped out of high school and gotten pregnant at an early age. And she got a GED. She wasn't college educated. So sometimes I was ashamed of the fact that my mother wasn't on the same level as the other parents.
而我的母亲，我们来自福利救济。她领福利。她高中辍学，很早就怀孕了。她拿了同等学历证书（GED）。她没受过大学教育。所以有时我对我的母亲没和别的家长处在同一水平这一事实感到羞耻。
Did you ever talk to her about that?
你和她谈过吗？
No. Because I've been ashamed to admit that to her. For a long time, I had been in denial about that. But I'm not ashamed of her anymore. I've grown out of that. I'm proud of her, as a matter of fact. I'm proud of her.
没有。因为我一直羞于向她承认这一点。很长一段时间，我一直对此予以否认。但我不再为她感到羞耻了。我已经走出来了。事实上，我为她感到自豪。我为她感到骄傲。
Well, yeah. I mean, look how far, look how much somebody had to push to make that happen.
嗯，是的。我的意思是，看看一个人为了实现那个目标必须付出多大的努力。
That counts more than a college degree.
那比大学学位重要得多。
When you look at your situation now, you're finishing your junior year right now--
当你审视你现在的情况时，你现在快要结束大三了——
Oh, it's finished.
哦，已经结束了。
It's finished. OK. Sorry.
结束了。好吧。抱歉。
I'm a senior, man. I'm a senior.
我是大四学生了，伙计。我是大四了。
Do you still feel like you're between worlds?
你仍然觉得自己在两个世界之间吗？
Oh, yeah. All the time. All the time. In one setting, the community where I come from, it's about not become white. And then at Brown, it's like not becoming-- yeah, it's the same thing, sort of. Not becoming white, remaining black in both worlds. Except it's sort of--
哦，是的。一直都在。一直都在。在一个环境中，也就是我出身的社区，重点是“不要变成白人”。然后在布朗，就像不要变成——是的，这是一样的，某种程度上。不要变成白人，在两个世界里都要保持黑人本色。除了这有点——
But at Brown, it's like being black but in their world.
但在布朗，就像是在他们的世界里做一个黑人。
Being black but in their world. Yeah.
在他们的世界里做一个黑人。是的。
Do you feel like you're in this kind of no man's land?
你觉得你是在这种无人区吗？
Sometimes. Sometimes.
有时。有时。
Like when?
比如什么时候？
This is difficult. It's hard. I've never really given it a lot of thought. I don't know. I get a lot of grief when I come home, especially from people in my church, people in my community, about going off to this white man's land. And it's just, you shouldn't do it, they're going to eat you alive. I mean, I still get that sometimes. And it does isolate me at times. And yeah, sometimes I do, I feel alone. I guess that's what you asked me. Do I feel alone, isolated in terms of my decision of going to Brown, venturing out? Yeah, I do. I do feel alone.
这很困难。这很难。我从未真正深入思考过。我不知道。我回家时会感到很多痛苦，特别是从我教堂的人，我社区的人那里，关于我去那“白人的土地”的事。就是说，你不该那样做，他们会把你活吞了。我的意思是，我有时仍然会听到这些。这确实有时让我感到孤立。是的，有时我感到孤独。我想那正是你问我的。我是不是因为去布朗、去冒险这个决定而感到孤独、孤立？是的，我确实如此。我确实感到孤独。
Do you feel less alone, though it sounds like you're feeling more alone when you go back home to Southeast Washington? Do you feel less alone now when you're up at Brown? And in that world?
当你回到华盛顿东南部时，虽然听起来你回到那里时会感到更孤独，但你是否觉得在布朗大学没那么孤独了？在那个世界里？
I do. Because I've grown more comfortable with Brown.
是的。因为我已经变得更适应布朗了。
In terms of feeling at ease in the new world that you have moved into, if we would consider somebody like your roommate Rob, who kind of grew up in that world, as being completely at ease, he's 100% at ease, where would you say your percentage is now?
就融入你进入的新世界的感觉而言，如果我们把你的室友罗伯这样成长在那里的孩子看作是完全自在的，他是100%自在，你会说你现在是百分之多少？
80%.
80%。
What's the 20% that still isn't there?
那还没有达到的20%是什么？
I still have a lot of growing up to do. I've come from Ballou High School, which is considered one of the worst high schools in DC. I've gone off to one of the best universities in the country. And I'm still not happy.
我还有很多地方需要成长。我来自巴洛高中，那被认为是华盛顿最差的高中之一。我去了全国最好的大学之一。但我仍然不快乐。
When you say you're not happy, you mean you're not happy in a day-to-day way, or you're not happy with how far you've come?
当你说你不快乐时，是指你日常生活中不快乐，还是对你所取得的成就感到不满足？
A combination of both.
两者兼而有之。
I mean, I guess I could imagine the day-to-day part of it because it just seem like it's so much work--
我的意思是，我能想象日常生活中那部分，因为它看起来就是太多的工作了——
It is.
确实。
--to keep things going.
——来维持一切运转。
This is really difficult for me to talk about. So you've got to bear with me here. Plus I haven't given this much thought. Success is a trip. Because we push people, especially blacks, to be successful, minorities to be successful. And then once they get there, and once we get there, for some reason, we pull each other back.
对我来说谈论这个真的很困难。所以你得忍受我。再加上我没深入思考过这个问题。成功是一场旅行。因为我们推动人们，尤其是黑人，去成功，推动少数族裔去成功。然后一旦他们到了那儿，一旦我们到了那儿，出于某种原因，我们又会互相拉后腿。
You're thinking specifically about things that are happening now that you're back home for the summer?
你是说具体关于现在你暑假回家时发生的事情吗？
Yeah. My biggest problems are at home. My biggest worries are at home. All these people who just bombard me with what they-- for some people, me going to Brown is like I've given up, or turned my back to the fact that I'm black, which is totally not the case.
是的。我最大的问题都在家里。我最大的担忧都在家里。所有那些人用他们的话语轰炸我——对某些人来说，我去布朗就像我放弃了，或者背弃了我是一个黑人这一事实，而这完全不是那么回事。
And this is people who you respect saying this to you. People in your church.
而且这是你尊重的人对你说的。你在教堂里的人。
People that I respected. People that I thought were really behind me. That's the toughest part. And that's what's hard. That's what I'm trying to deal with. Success is almost as worse as failure.
我尊重的人。我以为真正支持我的人。那是最高难度的地方。那很困难。那是我正在试图应对的。成功几乎比失败还糟糕。
Ron Suskind's great, great book about Cedric Jennings is called A Hope in the Unseen. You know, before our interview ended, I told Cedric about the story in the first half of today's show, about a black who said that he would date but never marry a white woman.
罗恩·萨斯金德关于塞德里克·詹宁斯的伟大著作名为《未知中的希望》。你知道，在我们的采访结束前，我告诉了塞德里克今天节目上半部分的故事，关于一个说他会和白人女性约会但绝不会娶她们的黑人。
That's interesting because I think the same way. Somebody asked me, first they asked me, would you marry a white woman? And I said no. And they said, well, would you date a white woman? And I said, yeah, I would date a white woman.
那很有意思，因为我也是这么想的。有人问我，他们先问我，你会娶白人女性吗？我说不。他们说，好吧，你会和白人女性约会吗？我说，会的，我会和白人女性约会。
The way the other guy on the show explains it, there's a part of him which doesn't believe that a white woman could completely understand him.
节目里的另一个人解释说，他内心有一部分不相信白人女性能完全理解他。
True, I guess. But I don't know. When two people bond in love, I think that they definitely understand things about each other, like more than what he's giving them credit for.
是真的，我想。但我不知道。当两个人因爱而结合时，我认为他们肯定能理解关于对方的事情，比他所给予的肯定更多。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Senior editor Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Laura Doggett and birthday girl Soyini Davenport.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由南希·厄普代克和我制作的，还有亚历克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德。高级编辑保罗·塔夫。特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗赫林和萨拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自劳拉·道格特和今天过生日的索伊尼·达文波特。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you want to buy a cassette of this program, call us at WBEZ here in Chicago, the phone number 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . Or you know, you can listen to nearly any of our action-packed programs for free on the internet at our website www.thislife.org. That's "this life," one word, no space. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买这期节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，电话号码312-832-3380。312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是 [email protected] 。或者你知道，你可以在我们的网站 www.thislife.org 上免费收听我们几乎所有激动人心的节目。“this life”是一个词，没有空格。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who makes us love him by strutting around all day in his--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他整天穿着他的——让我们爱他——
--faded, almost threadbare corduroys that fit him like a glove.
——那种褪色、几乎磨损、穿在他身上就像手套一样贴身的灯芯绒裤子。
Yes, indeed. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
是的，确实。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带给大家更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台 (PRI)。